On March 22nd 2016, two suicide bombers blew
themselves up at Brussels' Zaventem airport.
11 people were killed and more than 100 injured.
Islamic State claimed responsibility for the attack.
Air travel has always been a target
for terrorism. Since aviation began, there's
been more than 20 attacks on airports and
more than 100 attempted airline bombings.
And with increasing risk comes increased security,
most notably after the attacks of September 11th.
Airport security prevented liquids over
certain size on board. They enforced shoe checks.
They even started using body scanners.
Since 9/11 the positioning of the security
cordon as it were has really been at that
crossover between what we call the landside
of an airport that anyone can access and airside.
That means that anyone entering the airside
area and subsequently going onto a plane has
been scanned, searched, but what it's done
at the same time is leave large areas of the
airport essentially unprotected. Airports
in Tel Aviv, Nairobi, Mumbai: they all have
security checks before entering the terminal
building. There are certainly experts who
suggest that all that does is cause large
numbers of people to queue on the street in
just the place where they're potentially most
vulnerable; that you'll simply swap bombings
for drive by shootings. In other words, you'll
create a bottleneck and that will still put
people at risk. There's not only the question
of whether or not you simply move the terrorist
threat to another area; there are also costs
involved. Costs to the airports themselves.
But there are certainly also costs in terms
of time and the length of the passenger journey
and whether you actually make people not want
to even travel anymore. So no matter what
security officials decide there's always going
to be a toss up between the need for security
and the hindrance of travel.